Sebastian Stan hello welcome to the air
man how are you I'm well thank you
thanks for coming in my pleasure you
know what's amazing we were talking
about you yesterday and how you were
coming in Oh God and and I knew you as
as Bucky but I also knew use Jeff
Gillooly
is I didn't put two and two together
until that moment that you were the same
person
which think is a great compliment right
no for sure I mean Josh brawlin said the
same thing to me and we you know we'd
been doing some interviews together for
the film and finally like I guess he
figured that out and sent me an IKE a
nice email about of course it's the best
cop
that's great hanging out with you and
he's like oh my god it was you yeah so
when you playing Gillooly do you get do
you one of me are you the guy who wants
to meet someone first I think you have
to in some weird way I mean like you
know regardless will you hear the people
you know who you're meeting I mean and
and certainly there was also because
there was all I could find online and
was just unfortunately a very kind of
dark description you know of this guy
and and and I just in the movie we
needed to see him in various different
ways and and so yeah it was like if you
don't then it's weird so how you
contacted and what did you say look I'm
playing you and I was like he was he had
been really in touch with the writer I
mean he you know like the writer
basically seemed Rogers when an
interview Tanya and then Jeff's
separately and got like three hours
worth of and you know of information out
of both of them and then wrote the
script with their with their both with
their consent so he had been in touch
with with Jeff and then you know they
said you want to meet him and I said
sure you know I I so I went to Portland
Oregon I went to where they're from and
I went everywhere around and then I
finally tracked him down and we we got
dinner and then I just tried to you know
get as much info as I could well you
know what sorry I was it was he what you
expected or were you like oh okay this
is not the guy I thought he was no I
mean he was I tried really hard not to
walk in there with expectations I mean
it's it's hard to do that especially
when you're researching somebody but
yeah I mean in some ways it was it was
interesting because
everybody everybody has a story you know
story of what happened and and and
sometimes like that's your story or you
know so so he has his and you know I
think for me it was much more just being
curious with like who he was growing up
like what the origin how they met you
know what it was like at the beginning I
mean I knew all about the craziness but
you know it was more about and what are
his mannerisms I mean I couldn't find a
picture of the guy smiling you know even
just that was wanting to just kind of
like get in get an idea for no smile he
must listen to this show when you're
sitting down though like with somebody
and you're the actor that's gonna play
them you know that they're gonna put
their best face forward you know that
they're gonna wear what you want them
like they are going to if they're smart
show you person that they wanted to be
on I mean I agree made a pretty serious
[ __ ] detector I think I I would
agree with you like that would be the
the sort of approach I I would assume
but but um you know the first thing he
said to me was like listen like why
would they ever want to make a movie
about this
it's about what happened because it
shouldn't be celebrated and shouldn't
you know it's I don't want it you know
like we shouldn't have a attention
brought to it and I said look I mean you
know I'm not the writer but you spoke to
the writer and he wrote a pretty great
script and it's also about her really
yes it's her life story and getting a
different point of view of her and what
happened that you know she didn't get a
chance so much when it happened and you
know he was very supportive of that so a
certain kind of manipulation maybe maybe
are they still in touch or no I in real
life so no I don't know wife movie do
you think that they're still friends
yeah but I'm wondering do they ever
reconnect I mean they do have this bond
but I guess as an actor you have this
benefit of you don't have to have those
answers right like you don't have to say
whether this guy is a good guy or a bad
guy you have to just portray him as he
would perceive himself not the way you
perceive him right no I agree I mean I
have to start you have to get
well you're always you always have sort
of an objective one view of it but
you're you're you also have to kind of
leave the judgments at the door you're
right like to some extent you have to or
else you're never going to be able to
get anywhere believable you know like
you just won't be believable especially
if you have a radar of self-criticism
which is what I do then then I feel like
if I'm bullshitting I'm bullshitting but
you know I didn't have it there's it's
not my choice like everything you saw in
the movie was in the script you know the
way like all the funny business and then
all the hard stuff and and also you know
moments worth it it showed like they did
have a connection so I just have to
follow that as it's like it's like a GPS
for me basically is is getting involved
with the Marvel Universe at this point
is it like the greatest gig in Hollywood
because it just seems like every time we
talk to actors they talk about how like
the benefit of being on a series for
example is consistency you get this well
III a hundred percent would say I
probably uh you know I I'm not sure if I
would have gotten I Tonya had not been
for Marvel right you know in in one way
or another you know I mean I you know my
life certainly has changed inside since
you know I the first movie I was in it
was in in 2010 and and and I always give
credit to that because I think in terms
of exposure in terms of what it taught
me about kind of you know what I want
the relationships the directors like it
influenced everything on a huge scale so
yeah absolutely
you're always feeling very that it's a
privilege in a way and especially
because you know that there's so much
care from the top down about the final
product you know what you're getting you
know and and I think everybody pays
attention to what fans want what they
respond to what they don't you know like
they oh they're always I mean look
they've consistently made great movies
one after the other you know and if you
you could argue and you know people try
that you know there's fatigue or you've
seen this thing or whatever but they're
but they're always making a new take on
it they're always kind of keeping it
keeping you entertained in a different
way or giving you a different sort of
outlook so and they're doing it totally
indifferent
ways with different stories so it's kind
of you know epic and really difficult
yeah nine Pinscher deal I signed
something about ten years ago but that
doesn't really mean much as I'm saying
what is the moment when your agent comes
and goes alright they want you for nine
yeah I mean that's yeah here's what it's
like one you don't hear that you want
actors want to get one blockbuster right
we I want one summer blockbusters like
okay we're gonna we have nine
blockbusters for you citizen I mean
here's the thing you know at the end of
the day those things you know like words
or whatever that don't mean that much
because the truth is I feel like the
journey has always been fly by the seat
of your pants you know it's like there's
always a hope there's always a goal you
know in the sense of like yeah listen
like we would love to do this one day
you know like that's how it was always
presented to me you know when I was back
when I was see you know 2010 I mean that
was I don't even know I was like what 25
26 I can't remember but anyway like and
I'm sitting there going like well this
all sounds fantastic but again so much
has to go right in order for all that to
come to fruition I mean like at a point
in time like the whole deal could just
okay I might not make any more they
might okay one of those movies like moms
or something like so let's rethink I
don't think it's that so much as I would
say like early on when that was a
discussion about the future like
everybody was hopeful that people would
respond in the way that they have but no
one was banking on it I mean you know
it's do you have conversations in terms
of storyline about like and I'm not
asking for spoilers obviously but like
do they go like okay here's the vision
for this film here's the long-term
vision of where the pieces fit together
like you have some kind of idea in your
head of what Disney and Marvel I think
we hear much more the vision of the film
than the long-term vision
gotcha it's always much more about the
vision of the film then then there
anything else I mean you know like I
from me I've always looked at the comic
books and and try to filter in certain
aspects of my character and from what
I've learned there in terms of so that
one day maybe when you do look back you
start to go oh you know what like it's
interesting like I just picked something
up that
he was doing early on like I feel like
that would be cool to do but again it is
a lot of on a need-to-know basis right
and you are smart you audition for
Captain America I did because they
weren't having auditions for Bucky bars
at the time all that we're trying to do
is just cast Captain America and then go
forward and I just happened so they were
only seeing people for that and I happen
to go in for that and then they were
like oh you know what maybe he could be
right for that role and we didn't think
about that
how'd the audition go like did it go
good we like I think I got this really
odd there's no [ __ ] way I know it was
going well and the reason I the reason I
say that is because I gone and I think a
few times like I went in one time in LA
then I got a movie in Germany and then I
left and then I made another tape from
there and I sent a tape in they liked
that they had me do it another way then
I had to fly to LA and I went in again
and I auditioned again and then they
wanted a screen test me so I kind of
auditioned for Captain America at least
probably four times before I even got to
that point so you know you're going back
in again and again you're like oh like
maybe maybe it could work and I guess
that's they have to be that kind of
careful about who they cast because the
idea is we're gonna do like ten movies
hopefully if everything goes according
to plan and we don't want to be
switching characters no I know but the
whole time I was getting you know it was
exciting what I kept saying to myself
I'm like but I was born in Romania you
said they wanted you to do it another
way he said they had you do two
different way what did they ask you to
switch well they were first of all I
didn't grow up with the comic books so I
had no preconceived idea I had no a
knowledge of what was going on I mean I
even you know I'd heard Captain America
but I didn't know about the guy what the
story was so any I was going poorly
based on a scene that they were giving
me and there and they were giving me
direction to go look why don't you tried
a little bit more this way you know
here's a little bit background like so
they were educating me about the
characters that make sense yeah I tried
to play like an iconic character if
you've only looking at the scene and
you've never read the stuff or seen
anything on them so yeah I did we just
didn't have him in Romania
I believe in the comic book your
character Bucky eventually becomes the
new Captain America are you hoping that
like yeah that's a that's a narrative to
me we should we should we should go in
that direction
I mean look of course you know I would I
would certainly like you know jump on
and and and go for if that that was a
decision that was made which is
certainly not my decision right you know
I mean I've I've I've enjoyed every
aspect of the character so far that
that's been decided for him and it's
been a lot of fun I mean I think also it
would be a very different take on that
character I mean that's how it is in the
comic book support as it becomes a whole
more darker sort of more you know like
the the motivations behind Bucky being
Captain America and all that are very
you know very specific and and they're
just different but so you know it's so
much more complex than just asking
someone like do you want to do it it's
more like hey is this make sense from
what we've seen so far
character-wise where these people are
right now in their lives in the MCU and
going forward because Evan said he
doesn't to come back after the next one
I think 2019 after that he said he's
done but there was a you know there
we're promoting infinity war which is on
digital blu-ray August 14th but if he
doesn't come back that just is he really
never come back words contract ago there
was an incident in infinity war there
was an incident you know I don't want to
that could leave Wow you know usually
see the film and you should say the film
yeah to understand nothing yeah listen I
mean did I just blow somebody by saying
that it's no no no I mean that's public
that's public information no I mean but
you know like at the same time what you
just said really doesn't mean a whole
lot to say that after anything I've ever
said
you know yeah you could say I'm dumb I'm
done doing this play does it mean that
I'm never gonna be in a play well that's
a contract thing maybe he just wants
like you know I mean like and I guess he
goes back to that question about like oh
there's a 9 picture deal here and you're
like yeah it says done on a piece of
paper but it's still we're gonna see
what happens now is when when you I've
always wondered about the Marvel
Universe when because you've been in one
of the and a couple of the end credits
scenes when you just pop up in the end
credits scene mmm does that count as
like okay that's another movie I was in
honestly that's a good question are you
go do you count it for yourself is like
yeah that counts as me being in that
movie I don't know if I've thought about
it enough to be honest to think that I
think that would be a cameo I don't know
I mean I would say that right I cam you
know I don't know I mean the one one of
the one of the act I was in - well I was
in three one of the after credits scenes
was actually a scene from another
upcoming movie so you know right so is
that count I don't that movie or the
other movie or both movies or these are
things that I don't really blend of time
thinking about do you tell people yeah I
was in that movie like if there's a
movie and you're only in the end crap
will you tell people like yeah I was in
that movie uh no no I can't quite own it
like it's my movie I can't you know like
I mean I think you know like my mom went
to see Black Panther and and she was and
she came back and called me was like I
thought you were in the film and I said
[Laughter]
I don't think you sit through the
credits no it's it's a given every
Marvel movie you're supposed to sit
through the credit what's the modem but
you do that just that people got tired
of working on a film and no one says
through the credits and they're like
just do something at the end to get
people to sit through the credits I
don't know but you know I think it's
kind of great in a way because you know
you have like these little mini desserts
you know like after the whole thing
you're going back to I mean I think
part of it is this is my theory and
maybe more in the beginning than now I
think originally the idea was that there
would be people that would go back to
see it a second time because their
friends would be like you see the end
credits scene and you're like what what
there's a scene after the credits and
the real hardcore fans if they walked
out when absolutely because I knew
people would go back and see the movie a
second time because of that if you
wanted to see the end credits scene yeah
yeah yeah well I think listen it's also
another great way which is of just
putting in more material you know hours
yeah a little more so stick around I'm
up two and a half it's amazing watching
these things two and a half hours like
it's originally if you said two and a
half hours superhero movie you'd be like
what the hell would but they fly by but
that was yeah well this one in
particular I found I thought you know I
was like oh my god like I don't know how
they're gonna do it I really don't
because there's just so many people and
there's so many things going on at the
same time but you're watching it and
there's and and and you know there's so
much happening it's almost like every
scene has its own impact in its own way
and then by the end you're you're
actually you know you've forgotten that
you've been there for a minute
you know zone Jim Norton is also a comic
book movie actor I don't know if you
know that about it's not important I
originally spider-man but it's a pretty
significant part but like here I think
there's some I think there's some credit
than you see given to those movies I do
like aunt Tobey Maguire because you
gotta remember like that sort of kind of
start like rejuvenate first sort of that
was before the Batman's right then the
only no I think I owe the knowledge yeah
I think there Mikey yeah what about the
Michael Keaton right but I feel like say
that was a different
yeah the Joel Schumacher like the end of
that series of Batman movies kind of
killed superhero movies for a little
while yeah and then I I kind of in my
mind's eye the spider-man movies brought
back they disappear that was I always
remember that you know like when you and
now I feel like I even remember because
you did when I walked in I was like I
know I've seen before probably not in
that yeah you've per seen the other but
what did what did you do and I've seen
you I know I've seen yeah many times
if you do the line no I can't I can't my
work is my work you're right to live do
you do the theater yes yeah no I have
I've done it twice I did it yeah
2007 - in 2013 I was just looking at
Orlando Bloom had a thing where he was
yelling at a woman for her iPad I think
she would say someone said she was just
using it as a fan but it's amazing how
many people are it is an awful fan but
there was someone behind her who took a
photo so it looked like she was on her
iPad but she was used using this an
attention deficit you know is happening
I mean you know you know I mean disorder
that's obviously what it is but like I
mean it's just we I think people are
having a hard time like it's hard for
you to go and sit there for two hours
without looking at their phones and
that's in itself like terrifying but I
feel that look if you're you know as
long if if I was him I you know I get it
I mean you know don't break character
maybe stay in saying the thing but have
the character yelling why not you know
keeping it you know keeping in the world
but but you have to I believe there was
one time where don't you remember
hearing about when Hugh Jackman and
Daniel Craig did this two hander and it
was like two cops or whatever and and
they they stopped and somebody's phone
was going off and I think Hugh Jackman
in character was like we're gonna sit
here and we're gonna wait until that
phone gets answered and then we're gonna
continue you know and it's like but in
character yeah cool character he's
embarrassing for the person but it's
like turn your phone off [ __ ] they
they tell you before it starts and it
keeps you interested in the play if
they're in character like you don't have
to leave well I mean I think that's the
fun thing about theater sometimes that
you're not always safe you know as a
writer memory I mean you're that close
like anything can kind of sort of happen
yeah and it should feel like that you're
you're in there yeah are you family
Kowalski just told me to turn off my
iPhone are you are you method at all
like when you fall into Jeff Gillooly or
you do stay you have to stand your
genitals stay Gillooly no man I mean
listen I think I think you know
you you everything is it's always
different you know I'm always one of
those people that I just sort of feel
like you know whatever works for you you
know like just as long as it gets you to
be able to show up to work and be on
time and and and do your job as
truthfully as you can I don't
discriminate you know and there's never
really like a textbook for it I mean
there's there's there's movie sometimes
where it's just you know like if there
is a hard scene to do like maybe it's
not that great to talk to everybody on
set that day maybe it's a little bit
easier to sort of keep to yourself and
you know or but there's other times
where you want to be talking to people
because you want to kind of like keep
yourselves actually that is saving your
energy right you know and and so it just
varies I think yeah